- Lets think about what three divided
by one fourth is equal to.
Pause this video and see if you can
figure it out on your own.
And I'll give you a
hint, take three wholes
and divide it into pieces
or sections that are each
one fourth of a whole and then think
about how many sections you have.
Alright now lets work
through this together.
Now let me draw three wholes.
And so lets say this is...
I'm gonna hand draw it, so
its not gonna be perfect.
But lets say that is one
whole right over there.
This is two wholes right over there.
And then I have my third
whole just like that.
And now I'm going to divide it into pieces
or sections that are each
one fourth of a whole.
So this first whole is four pieces
that are each one fourth
each, of four fourths.
And then I have another four
fourths right over here.
Another way to think about
it, I took the three wholes,
and I divided it into fourths.
So if you divide it into fourths how
many pieces am I going to have?
Well this is pretty straight
forward, you have one
two three four five six seven
eight nine ten 11 12 pieces.
And I didn't even have to count that,
each whole is gonna be four fourths.
So three wholes is going to
be three times four fourths,
or 12 pieces or 12 sections.
So that is going to be equal to 12.
Another way to think about
it is if you take three
and you divide it into equal
sections that are each a fourth
you are going to have 12 equal sections.